all right so and or episode 10 is in the
books and uh yeah the prison break went
down without any of them choking on
their aspirations well except for this
guy and I guess um him and well I can't
forget about this guy okay okay some of
them did not make it but yeah in this
video we're gonna be discussing that
ending our theories for the next few
episodes along with our reaction and
review of this episode let's not waste
any time because there's only one way
out now if you enjoy this video then
program up and hit that like button as
it helps the channel and also don't
forget to subscribe for reviews and
Recaps like this every day with that out
of the way a huge thank you for clicking
this now let's get into Andor episode
10. and that
ends today
there is one
so if you're just coming out of episode
9 we heard Andy Circus drop in iconic
four words that'll give any Star Wars
fans chills for years to come
back as well
and that alone carries so much weight
here in episode 10 because we know Kino
is fully on board with attempting
andor's Escape Plan knowing that his 200
odd sum shifts left on his sentence mean
nothing because he will just be shifted
to a different part of the prison and
the whole thing starts over again with
time against them much like everyone in
this series the following day is the
best chance for them to kick the Escape
Plan into full gear surprisingly all of
this Echoes that of Andor and the rebels
preparing for the Garrison heist in the
previous episodes the plan was briefly
laid out you know in episode 9 with
Andor cutting whatever pipe that was we
discover it's a water supply of sorts
stopping the elevator halfway down and
using it to climb the rest of the way up
using the railing as help because again
from episode 9 it's revealed that the
railing and lift are not part of the
electrical floor grid the tension
building in this methodical Escape is
what has made Andor top-notch Star Wars
content because you're holding your
breath along with these characters
there's so many moving Parts with the
water slowly leaking the lift coming
down the prisoners on program but hiding
scrap metal behind their backs sure it
all Gets A bit chaotic with the initial
lift stoppage but once inmate 37 gets
crispy fried
um who uh by the way might be the MVP of
this whole Escape so uh uh poor poor one
out for him
[ __ ]
you
realizing the floor was no longer lava
Kino leading the charge had the same
feeling as the Garrison Heist after they
blew open the vault
this 16 plus minute Escape feels like a
huge spark to the Rebellion that we see
in later films because they are fighting
with nothing to lose and the Hope on all
of their faces when they realize that an
escape is happening that's what
rebellions are built on or some mumbo
jumbo Jin erso said in you know Rogue
one but the ending of this Prison Break
sees two things first of which is the
Heartbreak just rip it out of everyone
eagerly escaping but Kino Loy reveals he
cannot swim a man stuck in a prison to
die has the opportunity to escape only
to realize he is doomed either way the
writing for this character is so
perfectly tragic he would have probably
became a prominent member of the
Rebellion but stuck at the door of his
own Freedom there's nothing he can do
and this moment is played perfect by
circus with just the sadness in his eyes
who knows maybe the Empire comes back
tortures him and he becomes snoke eh but
the second thing is seen Andor and
melshi Escape onto the mainland of
narkina 5. we have seen that a majority
of this planet looks like a dense ocean
but here it's more of them escaping into
a Mesa almost Barren desert similar to
the Grand Canyon obviously we knew that
these two would Escape off this rock
together because of their appearance in
Rogue one but how they get off will be
up to our own guesses now this is only a
theory but narkina 5 being described as
a small Moon and we can see in the
distance or Horizon two other moons
along with a bright large planet how
funny would it be if this planet is
Naboo I mean Naboo is said to have three
different moons one of them having not
been named yet so Andor and melshi
escape to Naboo team up with Jar Jar
Binks and this is the final episode of
season one
now there was a bit of a theory stating
that the whole prison was a mental game
of torture where one group would build
these pieces altogether while the other
groups in the prison would essentially
deconstruct them and the cycle continues
this is why the Man released on level 4
and wound up back on level 2 was such a
major issue because he essentially saw
how the sausage was made I wouldn't put
it past the Empire to do something
sinister like this but it entirely feels
like a waste of resources so I'm
sticking to the theory of them building
pieces to the Death Star Free Labor it's
mentioned in later films that the
construction is behind schedule hinting
it's because of this prison break also
how poetic would it be that Andor helped
build the Death Star only to be one of
the key members to eventually destroy it
there's also a quote from circus himself
in an interview with Jake's takes shout
out for the interview but circus heavily
hints it's the Death Star in the
interview
um they are they are building something
for the empire
that is used for nefarious purposes so
I'm going to leave it there so uh yeah
uh Death Star confirmed another big plot
piece towards the end of this episode is
the meeting between Lutheran and
supervisor Lonnie a meeting with a
stranger of sorts was hinted earlier by
clela and it's established that Lonnie
and Luth and have some sort of
relationship I had a feeling Lonnie had
more to him because in previous episodes
he is acting a bit squirrely at times
it's a forced relationship of sorts
because Lutheran is very much
blackmailing him for information that
the ISB is collecting and what their
next steps with spellhouse and such are
Lonnie even reveals the stage death of
Krieger's pilot to bait him into the mix
now this conversation between the two is
so perfectly written because Lutheran is
expounding upon what he has given for
the Rebellion so what do I sacrifice
everything
with Lonnie realizing it's just a
fraction of what he is giving nothing in
comparison but the conversation also has
a double meaning of sorts hinting at
their own personal relationship it's
assumed that the two of them have kind
of had more of an intimate relationship
over the time almost in a sense a Romeo
and Juliet being from opposing forces
but then moved on with life and man is
this so well written the dialogue
between these two not only gives so much
more character development emotion
tension but is damn right more
entertaining than most of the action
sequences we've gotten in Star Wars in
recent memory hell all of this the
Imperial spy nature of everything is
light years ahead of General hux's
reveal in the rise of Skywalker
I'm the Spy what Luther now with
information on spellhouse pharynx and
Miro I think he is going to return to
Sagara asking for help again as for
where the final two episodes go it's
only a guess from us but I did go
through the footage that was released
for Andor and compiled all of the events
that we have not witnessed yet so um
potential spoilers here for anyone who
wants to go into the final two episodes
completely blind so Miro and some death
Troopers are gonna head back to
steerguard to gather more information on
the missing Imperial technology I could
see this being a place where krennic you
know from Rogue one is at least
mentioned and would be an interesting
kind of wrinkle to introduce him to play
a role in season two luthin uses this
Intel from Lonnie and goes back to
discuss with saw Guerrera there is a
warning of War on the horizon if they
move forward with their plan and it's
kind of a two-part plan with Guerrero's
men and Kriegers moving forward with the
raid on spellhouse but all of this is
actually distraction to allow for
Lutheran to attack the Destroyer where
Krieger's man is being held captive a
space battle with a handful of Tie
fighters will ensue and will get some
space of lightsabers or or whatever the
hell this thing is all of this will
alert Miro back to pharynx where
tensions are running High increased
number of Imperial mud Troopers I could
be wrong with that one show up in a
full-out war with the people of pharynx
occurs dozens of casualties as and or
partsways with melshi to return to
pharynx to meet with Marva Miro is on to
him killing Marva right before he can
escape from the planet which is the
final straw for him to fully be against
the empire and a key member of the
Rebellion again this is all theories
pulled from footage so none or all of it
could happen but Star Wars likes to have
multiple big events play together at the
end of their movies so spell house
luthin and ferric's action sequences all
playing simultaneously seems fit sitting
hey it could happen as for this episode
I I don't know how much more I can say
than it was incredible Andor has topped
itself week in and week out and is
easily easily friends the best Star Wars
has been in a long long time Andy Circus
though amazing in this Last Arc his
portrayal development and speech and
moments he had in this episode shows if
you just get some bomb ass Talent with a
solid script and or is what you get in
return the conversation between Lonnie
and Lutheran was even some bang-up
kick-ass Star Wars underworld Espionage
spy that I would love to see more of in
this Star Wars World Star Wars Star Wars
world that's tough to say but obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on
episode 10 of Andor and what you think
these final two episodes have in store
maybe a huge scarif-esque battle and
I'll let you know we are currently
running a competition right now giving
away three copies of top gun Maverick on
the 15th of November and all you have to
do to get a chance of winning this is
like this video make sure to subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
Down Below on your thoughts of Andor
episode 10. we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of last month's contest are on
screen right now so if that's you
message Paul on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch be sure to check out some of our
other cool videos whether it be our
smile ending explained or our Ant-Man
quantumania leaks video with that out of
the way thanks for your constant support
I've been Jared and I'll see you in the
next one take care and peace